le train de Charlevoix qui relie Québec
à La Malbaie est bien connu des
touristes dès l'été prochain son
parcours servira de bancs pour les
énergies vertes l'idée du projet
aujourd'hui c'est de faire fonctionner
un train
à l'hydrogène vert le géant ferroviaire
Alstom soit tester sa technologie pour
la première fois en Amérique du Nord un
train à hydrogène circule depuis 2018 en
Allemagne il a le potentiel de
transporter jusqu'à 120 personnes sur
plus de 1000 km sans générer de gaz à
effet de serre l'hydrogène devient et
deviendra une alternative viable et donc
c'est ce qu'on veut démontrer avec ce
projet sauf qu'à l'heure actuelle la
production d'hydrogène nécessite des
quantités considérables d'électricité
dans un contexte tous les surplus
d’hydro-québec risque de disparaître
d'ici 2030 il apparaît peu probable que
cette source d'énergie puisse être
utilisée rapidement à une échelle
commerciale après avoir déclaré cette
semaine que la majorité des projets
d'hydrogène ne seront pas financés par
Québec Pierre Fitz Gabin précise sa
pensée ce que j'ai dit c'est que le les
demandes industrielles que nous avons
reçues excède
le ministre rappelle qu'une part
importante de nos transports lourds ne
pourront être alimentés par batterie si
le Québec doit réussir à décarboner son
économie d'ici 2050 il devra
éventuellement miser sur l'hydrogène
pour l'instant pour l'instant avec les
technologies ça prend beaucoup
d'électricité c'est pas très rentable de
le faire mais on peut pas se permettre
de pas investir dans l'hydrogène vert le
train à hydrogène circulera sur les
rails de Charlevoix entre juin et
octobre prochain le projet est évalué à
8 millions de dollars la contribution
gouvernementale s'élève à 3 millions ici
Olivier Lemieux Radio-Canada Québec